[Music]
you know it is a rare day when Britney
Spears decides to sit down for an
interview but tonight only we have her
and she's ready to talk oh yeah she was
and I have to admit I didn't know really
what to expect going into this because
she's been through so many ups and downs
but this is a special time in Britney's
life she just launched an important tour
and she's about to celebrate a major
anniversary that baby one more time it's
in 20 years yes coming up this year does
it feel like it's been 20 years it's
been so fast you know like I feel like I
just started yesterday you know so it's
like everything still feels very new
which I guess is a blessing yeah it's
been a roller coaster what would you
tell that Brittany from 20 years ago
I would tell that Brittany just to leave
in yourself and never doubt yourself and
be strong i sat down exclusively with a
36 year old for her first solo sit-down
in nearly two years and let me tell you
she's all about her son's firm and Sam
Askari
for music
and she's expanding her reported 215
million dollar music and beauty empire
with her new fragrance prerogative
available at Walmart and Kohl's why did
you choose that particular name you know
what I think it's so bold it's like no
judgments and there's no labels and it's
just it's very fresh and I feel like
it's really you know powerful and sexy
for girls to have the image of
empowerment and to have a little bit of
the ego it's okay you know on toot your
own horn I think that's kind of really
important these days what would you say
you're most confident about I just want
to be a happy person that's really
important is to spread joy you know and
yeah a happy person
so what are you least confident about oh
and the Lord I'm least confident than a
lot of things but of course all of us
girls were like oh my god what's this on
my arm my legs what's going on my booty
ooh
today Britney posted this
behind-the-scenes look pretty sexy stuff
it was a photoshoot for her new perfume
if you ever let the boys smell it and
help you choose oh no they were like mom
we don't want a little men perfume
though I love men's perfume oh my god
just come talk to me please like the
smell the aroma of men's perfume no my
cute boys are teenagers now they're 11
13 so they they're starting to wear men
[ __ ] already know yeah it's wonderful I
love men perfume like did you call it
men perfume what am I saying am i six
years old I love men perfume I like it
it sounds better than men's cologne no I
like men's cologne that's a little
better
Minn perfume I like them in perfume no
it's cute
[Music]